Michael oh hi Judy want some pizza
bad place crew delivered a hundred of
these to my office all Hawaiian the
worst pizza
Michael I murder Janet I knew about
Eleanor from the beginning I've been
trying to help her become a better
person and when she found out that your
retirement meant that you would be
tortured she immediately tried to find a
way to prevent it Eleanor is learning
she's just doing it after she died I did
enjoy her company but this is not Little
League there is no award for most
improved player Jeannie well maybe there
should be one final note the dining car
is at the very back of the Train it
serves only room-temperature Manhattan
clam chowder and also it's closed okay
here we go
[Music]
stop this train
dude what the fork not leaving what was
her not yet come on wait you want to
keep her bro that's our girl we agreed
on this know what we agreed on was that
this was a mistake
Trevor we're an uncharted territory here
until we can sort this out she stays
with us all right fine but until this is
resolved we're keeping the other Eleanor
fine what I'm sorry the other Eleanor
yet the real Eleanor the one that was
supposed to be here but got sent down to
us instead she's on the train
Eleanor come on out
hi everyone I'm Eleanor she'll stop
[Music]
you